you say you got the guitar how old were
you uh almost 13. all right 13. you get
this guitar and this style of yours
where you pick no I didn't start with
that how did you start
with a with a pick a flat pick yeah and
uh
learning the chords well my father
taught me when I said I really want to
learn to play these songs Earth Angel
he taught me
[Music]
he said
and they
[Music]
so he taught me those chords and they
they fit
oh maybe ninety percent of the songs
that were that I first heard and finger
picking now how would he listen this is
what finger picking is and it's called
Travis picking and it's named after
Merle Travis who's the con you know the
great country guy and it's it goes like
this
[Music]
thing with this kind of picking is the
thumb is always moving like this
[Music]
and then the other fingers go
so if you take that
and you go into a Sun Records you get to
[Music]
train ride
16 causes low
so there's that but there's also
[Music]
the poor boy the story is held and told
is squanders his resistance for a pocket
full of mumbles such a promises
so that's how when I first learned how
to use finger picking which I then at
that time I was using finger picks thumb
pick and two finger picks now I only use
my nails but I I put an acrylic on my
nail so that they're very hard so if I
want to play
oh
I'm not gonna break my nails you know
when did you know you were a really good
guitar player I am a good guitar player
but the guitar is is uh like a universe
you can never come to the end of what
you can what you can learn from it you
still love it like you get up I don't
know what your day is like but do you
get up and like I I really want to play
the guitar today it's akin to that
feeling it's like if I don't play I'm
I'm uncomfortable really even to this
day like I mean I every day I play every
day it's not like I play every day and I
practice I'm not practicing I'm just
fooling around with uh
fooling around with stuff the last stuff
I was fooling around with sounds like
[Music]
foreign